2 les transactions sont définitives
est ce que je peux voir votre
autorisation d'accès je m'appelle paul
michaels je vais avoir mon père
c'est quoi cet endroit fort jim
harrington est une retraite sur
invitation unique en son genre on les
cadres d'entreprises qui ont besoin de
se ressourcer il faut qu'on sépare
fouiller les baraquements trouver les
cibles
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ce délire une
sirène pour les recherches
emmenez là la forteresse
ces lieux à une armature en acier et des
murs en béton de plus de 45 cm
d'épaisseur
ici c'est une planque du gouvernement
c'est ça l'endroit où se mettait une
base militaire dissimulé qui sont ces
gens c'est frédéric balzarini
ce n'est pas possible je vous promets
que si cette inévitable qui veut quoi
moi
il a mis à mal tout le capital de
balzary le point culminant d'une
carrière quand diouf 600 millions qui
s'envole en un clin d'oeil
robin ne t'avait ça
jamais
un dernier message j'aurais dû te tuer
aurait dû étant révolue et aurait pu
ce cirque assez duré je partirai pas
sans mon père va t'en au moment où tu
m'as trahi je suis impliqué paul et tu
l'a précipitée vers la mort
t'approche pas de mon fils